it's a big thing for us to
the industry and for us to learn about
the science because it's this regulatory
system that has to embody all of these
concerns of yours and knowledge that you
have and this is a difficult thing for
our legal system to sort out because the
federal government that Hannah Geist
describes has limited delegated
authority to deal with these things they
can't just regulate all aspects of
fracking the state government says has
circumference showed have under the
Tenth Amendment reserved all powers not
delegated to the federal government and
that means power over property power
over land power over industrial
operations which is what was just what
hydrofracking is and then there's local
governments local governments have been
given authority to regulate a lot of
impacts that you haven't talked about
much today I've heard several people
talk about what are the risks of
fracking what are the risks and I think
the circumference is much larger than
we've talked about because there are a
lot of local impacts that are not
regulated at the state or federal level
so we wonder why can't industry just
decide these things and I think John I'm
indebted to you for your remarks we've
got to get this right we have to get
these industry best practices into the
regulatory system and how does
scientific standards fit into this
regulatory system that's what we're
about on our end of this debate and
discussion so the REA the feds have left
many impacts unregulated the state's
historically have regulated guests and
oil mining and the states have met left
many local impacts unregulated let's
take a look at some of these local
impacts and some Hannah just describes
some of the states are regulating some
of these things but from a local
perspective what we're first concerned
about is our land use pattern we're
concerned about our community we're
concerned about our comprehensive plan
we're concerned about our neighborhoods
we're concerned about a whole number of
things that have been outside the
discussion so far today we're concerned
about traffic safety and road conditions
and repair and dust from the trucks
we're concerned about noise and night
sky illumination view sit view shed
interruption local economic development
plans that we
that may include things other than the
gas and oil industry wetlands and
habitat protection are concerns of ours
at the local level along with soil
erosion and sedimentation ridge line
protection and protecting critical
environmental areas that we've taken a
long time the last 20 years to identify
and there are many many more so it could
be that land use law which I teach and
and I run a center called the land use
law center at pace law school and we now
have for land use courses in the FES
curriculum and we're about to bring on a
clinic in land use land use may be a
special case because the federal
government has made it very clear in a
number of statutes that we don't touch
land use that's a state concern state
legal authority state defer at the
legislative level to local governments
because all politics is local and most
state legislators are from local areas
so they defer to local authority and
local concerns and then we have this
comprehensive scheme in states that go
completely to another point on the on
the regulatory map where we have given
local governments the authority to adopt
comprehensive plans to adopt zoning and
we have told them that it's the land
that they've regulated that they can tax
which revenues they then take to pay for
municipal services and this is a state
regulatory construct this planning and
zoning and municipal finance and
municipal operations and you see what
the state governments have done is
create all this law that says that's our
system for deciding what goes where on
the landscape so you can't push this
level of regulation out when you begin
to talk about hydrofracking so in i'm
going to go real quickly through the
marsalis states and talk a little bit
about what's going on there's this
tremendous confusion in New York where
the oil gas and solutions mining law
says that it supersedes all local laws
or ordinance relating to the regulation
of the gas mining industry but shall not
supersede local
roads in real property taxes that sounds
pretty clear on his face we just pushed
the local governments out the door but
did we did we and it turns out it's a
very long story in New York the courts
don't agree so far with that with that
statement on its face what it seems to
say that the local governments are
preempted there's in fact because of
this three-legged stool that I just
talked about there's a presumption
against preemption of local law zoning
empowers local residents it furthers
democratic values it's part of a whole
comprehensive legislative scheme
judicial preemption at this local law
control denies those values are our law
says that local power shall be liberally
construed so does this then mandate a
very narrow reading of this super
session language and the courts have
said that it does the town of Dryden and
the town of middlefield in I want to
point out what's happening here because
it's not at least on one level it's not
a good thing these two towns talk to
their lawyers and their lawyers that you
have the authority to regulate
hydrofracking and so they both did it by
preventing it in the entire jurisdiction
now John to your point if we if at the
local level we regulate out gas drilling
we're going to have the state's slapping
our hands and doing something to control
that but these two towns did that in
different ways and they were both sued
dryden by a drilling company in
Middletown by a local dairy operation
that had least its land to a drilling
company and both courts at they at the
at the lower court level held that
zoning can regulate the location of gas
drilling while the Department of
Environmental Conservation has the
exclusive authority to regulate drilling
operations not a clear distinction but
so much of what we've heard today from
the industry and from the environmental
community is that there are things
associated with the actual drilling and
the operations of the gas itself of the
the pad and all of the all of the extra
facilities that that is regulated by
state so you get a single permit that
tells you what you have to do with
respect to your operations but at the
location and all these local land use
impacts are still within the regulatory
authority of the local governments so
they said there's no Express preemption
in New York State the statute creates
separate regimes for regulation and the
oil gas solutions mining law deals with
operations of these facilities and
zoning deals with their location and
local impacts and they can be
interpreted to coexist and so we're not
pre-empting local regulation think of
that 1600 local governments in New York
State as of today have the authority to
regulate this industry now in
Pennsylvania the state legislature stood
up tall and said we don't want any of
that we don't want any local
interference in regulating the
hydrofracking business so they took it
away with what that was called act 13
and it not only preempts all local
zoning regulation of hydrofracking it
requires all local governments to put
oil and gas operations in as as of right
uses in every zoning district in this
state and I think there's 2,600 local
governments in Pennsylvania so the
effect is according to the court that
looked at this act 13 the effect of this
act 13 is to violate provisions of local
comprehensive plan and local laws as two
uses hypes screening fencing noise
lighting all those other impacts that I
just mentioned the state legislature has
said no you going to put fracking in as
an as of right in every single zoning
district and in a case 2012 case called
Robinson versus Commonwealth which was
very narrowly decided the court in
Pennsylvania held that the pre-emptive
effect of act 13 is invalid and what it
says is it makes a rational distinction
so that if the local government had
decided that hydrofracking facilities
could go anywhere in any zoning district
that would be called an arbitrary and
capricious decision irrational and it
would be set aside by the courts the
court looked at this actor
cain is the same thing with the state
legislature that's just too arbitrary to
require even residential zones to have
hydrofracking facilities so the current
situation in Pennsylvania is a little
bit like we have in New York there were
two cases decided before act 13 before
the Robinson case and one held that the
local government could control the
location of wells consistent with
established zoning that was a Huntley in
huntley case and the other case held
that local land use cannot regulate
operations like wellhead construction as
Salem Township tried to do now in West
Virginia Morgantown has been as a city
it's been going crazy trying to regulate
fracking they first regulated fracking
out of the area one mile beyond its
borders that was set aside by a court
they then came back and they set aside
certain areas within which fracking
couldn't happen they required setbacks
from churches hospitals they care
residential areas etc and that is
probably now going to be litigated so
the question becomes given the
three-legged stool that I talked about
in the tremendous power that's been
delegated to local governments with
respect to planning and zoning when
Morgantown comes back with a more
reasoned and less extreme regulation is
it going to be upheld or are they going
to say the same thing that they said in
the first Morgantown case that this
Authority has been taken away I think
that the local law that I've talked
about in West Virginia has a lot of not
a strength and could lead to the same
results as we've seen in Pennsylvania
and New York and then in Ohio we have
this newberry township case which said
that local governments can regulate
fracking if they can discretely show
that it's for local public health and
safety reasons that they're doing they
regulated out fracking from all
residential districts and it turned out
that all the residential districts had a
lot of agricultural land in them they
had no agricultural zoning and they were
the courts decided that there's no basis
for for preventing fracking in those
residential areas because it's been no
showing that it protects local public
safety and health
so we're very much in the same position
oh hi Oh as we are in New York and
Pennsylvania and I think we may be in
West Virginia so the presenting
questions is my last slide the
presenting questions are how can the
federal state and local local regulatory
regimes be coordinated you see what
we've got is a very fractured to use the
term regulatory system and then as we go
about this how can the federal state and
local regulatory regimes be informed by
the science that you know I was struck
so many times this afternoon as I was
listening to you about how would I
possibly communicate what you were
communicating to us to local officials
we're trying to regulate some of these
impacts we need to be able to do that is
it possible for a state regime and
Hannah this of the interesting question
for us to collaborate on to protect the
interests that are normally protected by
zoning because if it's not possible for
the state government to do that then
there's got to be some room left for
local governments to regulate but then
how do we how do we measure this as John
said this is a tremendous economic
opportunity for our country and for our
local communities to take advantage of
this an incredible resource that we
found and we've got to be sure that we
do this correctly so how can we give
local governments and meaningful
meaningful role and state decision
making how can we maybe expand state
decision making so that includes some of
these local impacts how do we put in the
right place the regulations of science
the best practices from the industry
into this rather difficult to understand
regulatory system thank you thank you
you